I just want to plug that next month
we're gonna try something a little bit
different we're gonna do a series of
lightning talks so everybody here should
get involved go sign up at tiny dot cc
a tube hydrated lightning provide your
first and last name email address you
don't even have to tell us where your
talk title is if you you don't want to
really it's just meant to be unpolished
talks talk about anything whether it's
from anything from maybe you're hiring
in your company job descriptions write
projects that you're hacking on
tinkering with if you're in academia any
projects that you're working on they're
meant to be ten minutes or less you
don't have to take up the full ten
minutes you can take up five if you
wanted to just tell us about your data
journey your data project even your data
failures it would be greatly appreciated
it says data science isn't perfect right
so please do go ahead and sign up we've
got a couple people signed up already
but please go on and sign up this will
be October and I think you'll see that
the data up there ok so obviously
acknowledgments we'd like to thank num
focus TD Ameritrade for sponsoring this
space also doing duo for letting us take
some a Brian's time as well as for - for
obviously providing the food here as
always important points for people who
are new here emergency one right here
and there's one right outside the front
door that you're on your right hand side
we're always soliciting for speakers so
if you would like to speak in the future
or your like to nominate a good speaker
whether it's the local or across the
country please help us reach the far
depths of the data science world and as
always we're welcoming feedback so
either contact us on our meetup page or
you can always tweet hi dear Ann Arbor
or email us I've had you dinner at
gmail.com and for the sake of our
speaker please hold all of your
questions to the end unless they're
clear okay and remember that you're in a
board with space so please clean up
after yourself if at all possible or
maybe help out others to that forget
I'd like to always be in our Court of
conduct just as their reinforcement so
high data aesthetically
to providing a harassment free meeting
experience for everyone regardless of
gender sexual orientation gender
identity and expression disability
physical appearance body size race or
religion we do not tolerate harassment
of meeting participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meet up events be kind to
others do not insult up or down other
attendees behave professionally remember
remember that harassment and sexist
racist or exclusionary jokes are not
appropriate for pedido
attendees availing these rules may be
asked to leave the meetup at the sole
discretion of the meetup organizers but
thank you for helping us make this a
welcoming friendly environment for
everybody
quick icebreakers again here's an easy
one so turn to you there's somebody on
your left or your right introduce
yourself and tell them what is your
favorite mode of transportation or the
more that you get them get to work -
right yeah yeah
three
so hopefully you will leave today at
least knowing one other person we always
select to talk about sort of this month
in native science just a quick little
tidbit so I don't know if every anybody
heard but both Facebook and Microsoft
partnered up to offer this did I guess
open-source way to define open-source
standard to define neural networks so
that you can make it transferable across
different frameworks they call it onyx
or o N and X so check it out it's called
the open neural network exchange and
also the big data ignite nonprofit group
out of Western Michigan reached out and
they're having a conference out in Grand
Rapids from September 27 to 29 and they
are registration is open they also
offered some discounts so if you're
interested in attending shoot us a
message and we'll get the coupon code to
you so this is big data ignite comm I'm
not sure I will believe you LSU and
again O'Reilly has been kind enough to
offer us some free ebook so if you
haven't signed up for one yet
O'Reilly comm front slash pub front
slash PI data and Arbor so you can grab
one of these six ebooks and if you
actually go ahead and clone our github
repo these slides will be up there as
well or you can just ask me at the end
and always as always if you have any
announcements about job hires you can
always send me an email hopefully two
weeks prior to the Meetup and I can add
into this life seed emergent is hiring
both for our advanced analytics team as
well as our analytics Center of
Excellence so they're looking for both
data size data analysts at multiple
levels and this is for Ann Arbor
location as well as for my team I work
on the
technology team as a data scientist
exploring emerging technologies that
help us differentiate ourselves from our
competitors and so we do I do a ton of
research and development so we get to
build up brand-new peel up roots of
concepts that are meant to sort of prove
out the point of any sort of new
technology so please if you're
interested either go to careers dr.
Murray calm or chat with me afterwards
we'd love to have you
next event again is the pod unit
lightning talk October 10 so please go
and sign up and then with that I'd like
to introduce our speaker tonight so by
the witherspoon coming from dual
security he is an engineer on their data
engineering team and today he's going to
be talking about biggish data and I'm
sure he'll I'll tell you more let's
welcome my Brian I think so
everyone hear me in the back great great
Thank You Sean thank you all for coming
here today knowing me to speak to you so
just this is my first time at PI data so
I kind of want to just do a little quick
poll get to know you guys a little bit
if you are a if you consider yourself to
be a data scientists can you just joined
okay how about like a web developer web
developers okay and we work on on SAS
products ok software-as-a-service yes
cloud applications ok Python developers
a lot of Python here I hope cool any
JavaScript developers in front-end code
cool
last question who's seen Dark Knight
Rises ok great if you have it first act
of Dark Knight Rises the the big theme
is Batman having bank
crime in Gotham has sort of recused
himself from society a little bit and
his regressed physically and socially
and culminating in the end of the first
act when he gets into the big fight with
bane and Bane and towards the end a
fight yells him victory has defeated you
this is kind of what I want to talk
about a little bit if if you work on web
applications or cloud applications
oops this is probably the environment
you're used to working in you have your
trusty web browser your trusty Python
web application in your trusty database
your database probably has a few hundred
rows of data or maybe a thousand but but
a lot of this is fixed your data that
this is this is the development
environment I have for my product you
will maybe if you're working on a new
feature you'll write some some sequel
queries and everything will work just
fine and maybe you'll go through a code
review with your team and and people
look at the query maybe they'll spot
something that suggests it could be slow
maybe not but maybe you'll pass code
review and this will get deployed to
this which is production production is
much more complicated than that thing
that was running on your laptop there
are many other processes talking to your
database your database is much much
bigger there's a lot more data in it and
so we we talk about something in in
software development oh this is actually
production because I'm the web developer
so everything is Internet Explorer which
makes me sad but so so this is the
diagram I like to or a graph I like to
point out a lot this is the cost of
fixing issues relative to where they
occur so if you find issues in
development they tend to be much less
costly to fix you you can you can tweak
your sequel query or you know you can
that bug that happened but but when
stuff moves into production things
become much more expensive to fix
some things you have to do roll backs or
hot patches and you might risk downtime
low performance and stuff like that so
in a duo I do most of my development way
over the left in the middle we have
these these environments that we deploy
to is sort of like QA of sorts we have
we have a small production like
environment that we test stuff on smoke
test stuff before we push it out to
production sometimes we catch issues
there sometimes that slow sequel query
will will turn turn itself up in QA but
the worst case scenario is everything
works fine and you push it out to
production and it just just barely works
it is good enough at the time that it's
deployed because what ultimately happens
is something like this your your product
your feature your company is wildly
successful and all of a sudden you're a
production environment that once had
millions of rows now has hundreds of
millions or billions of rows and that
query that you wrote really starts to to
wear down your service and so what I
want to talk to you about this evening
is success and the problems that arise
with success so this talk is going to be
more broad than deep I'm going to cover
a lot of different aspects of
application development and how it
pertains to data analytics and what
we're doing at duo to to improve how we
present data so my name is Brian
Witherspoon I'm a principal software
engineer at duo security
I've been at duo since about April 2014
which means that in start-up years I've
been there for about 45 years
I joined duo mainly as a front-end
developer so I've done a lot with UI
design and development but in the past
18 months or so I'd been transitioning
into more of a full stack developer and
and concerning myself more with with
data infrastructure and data
visualization so that's what I'd like to
talk to you about today yes front-end
development so I'm on the data
engineering team at duo this is a
relatively new team we kind of started
ourselves right around maybe January
this year or so and I wanted to just
briefly explain what we consider data
engineering to be because I think
there's maybe just a bit of confusion in
what data engineering is maybe compared
to data science and the way I like to
understand the differences between data
engineering and data science is if you
remove data from the equation and you
consider the differences between
engineering and science to summarize
this this take that in for a second more
seriously so the way I like to think
about science and engineering and data
science and data engineering is to think
about the layers of abstraction in the
directions that both of these roles
operate in so scientists will make
observations they will capture data they
will examine that data and maybe in for
patterns and come up with theories and
build data models and then engineers
will take those theories and models in
design systems and implement and
maintain those systems and then those
systems will then in turn hopefully
provide meaningful data back to those
data scientists to to further refine
those data models and so you have this
kind of nice little feedback loop
basically data scientists move from
concrete to abstract and engineers move
from abstract to concrete and I think
that this applies to the realms of data
science data engine
as well so with within duo
we've we've started to kind of separate
these two roles a little bit we do have
a data science team and their chief
focus is as I kind of mentioned data
modeling and also doing some exploration
into machine learning technology data
engineering on the other hand we are
concerning ourselves with improving how
we store data how we move it around our
our cloud stack and how we visualize it
to our customers
sorryi notes are bugging out there we go
so take a step back I wanted to just
briefly introduce duo what what our
product or service is and the what value
we provide to our customers duo we
provide what we call trusted access
services to our customers and what what
trusted access means to me is basically
making sure that users who are trusted
by the organization using devices that
are healthy can access the applications
that they are meant to access beyond
that duo provides additional value to
its customers through our cores and
two-factor authentication but we also
want to provide value to our customers
by helping them better understand how
users are accessing applications in
their in their network either whether
they be on-premise or in the cloud to
that end I want to introduce two of our
primary user personas and this this is
going to help kind of establish sort of
the data that we collect and how
important that is to these users the
first user is Gary he's an IT
administrator
data security is only a portion of his
job he's the one who's mainly
responsible for configuring duo and
setting up duo in front of his on prime
and cloud applications he's constantly
seeking improved technology ninety
services for his employees he's he has
to deal with a lot of information so
he's really concerned only on things
that are out of the ordinary he's also
kind of an older version of Dane Cook
for some reason the other the other
person I'd like to introduce her name's
Eve she is an employee of the same
company that Gary works at she's an
end-user and she needs to be able to
access a variety of applications Gmail
office maybe they have a wordpress blog
all these things are important to her to
be able to get to when she needs to she
gets frustrated when security gets in
the way or adds friction to her job and
she's she's not an expert in security or
technology although she knows that
security is an important thing it's it's
never at the forefront of her mind so
with with these two user personas
there's another kind of loop involved
here
Gary's responsible for setting up duo
and configuring it Eve's responsible for
using it when Eve uses it that provides
data which I'll talk a little bit about
in a minute back to Gary Gary is able to
use that data to further refine how that
how his system is configured and
hopefully provide Eve with a more secure
and not blocking part from being able to
do her job
my purpose as a developer a duo is to
help provide Gary with the information
he needs when he needs it so at the
center of all of this is this concept
that we call the auth and the auth is
basically a record of the interaction
that Eve has with our service every time
Eve
a push notification or answers her phone
and says yes this is me or no this isn't
me or anytime she enters a passcode into
our service we record that information
so we consider this to be our largest
and most critical source of data there's
a lot of information that we can we can
gather through this one single
interaction we're able to identify who
it is in the system we know that maybe
Gary has configured it to say this is
for real name
Gary can assign Eve to certain user
groups within our system so we know that
information there's also the application
that's what this rocket is supposed to
represent is she accessing WordPress is
she access in her VPN you see accessing
office 365 and then where there's a lot
of really good information is in the
devices she's using so if I if I attempt
to sign into something on my laptop and
I use my smartphone to do 2fa I'm able
to do I was able to to know what what
operating system I'm using on both these
devices what web browsers I have if I'm
running plugins like flash or Java
understanding security features of the
smoke of the smartphone like if there's
you know fingerprint lock enabled or if
the device is encrypted we have all this
information we know the IP addresses of
all of both of these devices and so we
can infer things like where these
devices might be in the physical world
as well as the reputation of these IP
addresses are they coming from tor
networks or or commercial VPNs or
something like that so there's a lot of
really awesome information in here that
we do it would like to gather in store
both so we understand what's going on in
an industry level but also to provide
this information back to Gary so that he
can make intelligent decisions at least
this is what we want to have happen but
currently oh there's also some
additional metadata that we can collect
like there's there's IDs time stamps we
know what customers involved and so on
and so forth
we do that big lead up again this is
what we want to have happen but not we
it's not like that because these kinds
of queries are very expensive for us for
some reason being able to select all the
rows from a table where the username is
equal to X is painfully slow for us and
has been this way for a little while
effectively victory has defeated us
because now we have so many rows in our
table that it's really hard to do
cumulatively currently we have about I
would say about three and a half billion
rows across all of our deployments out
there in the world just to kind of set
the the scope of the scale that we're
dealing with here yes my sequel yep
so I'll come back to that this this
these rows are spread out amongst a
handful of databases we deploy our code
to multiple regions in AWS we have
multiple instances of my sequel running
but there's there's an average of about
60 million rows on certain databases the
largest one has about 1.7 billion there
are some certain things that we have
done to sort of help improve the
performance of my sequel reads we have
read-only replicas that we have out
there we've we've implemented database
sharding so taking that customer ID and
basically spreading data out to multiple
RDS instances based on which customer ID
is involved the the thing that we we
know that could provide the the best
read performance for us would be to add
more indexing however this is kind of a
non-starter for us right now at this
point this would be the general process
for us for adding an index to production
we would create a read replicas and we
would migrate that ring grab a cloth and
then eventually we would cut over a
problem with this is that the the rate
in which we're receiving new records is
so great that these migrations would
take a very long time to complete and
the risk of data loss we're just a
little too worried about also adding
indexes means that
rightly and see we go up and that's a
very important thing for us especially
considering that rights to this database
could possibly add lag time to being
able to sign into her service so all
this going on there's there's there's
really a lot of missed opportunities for
us we have all this data we do provide
ways for Gary to pull it out of our
system in in CSV or JSON formats and
some of them take advantage of that
they'll take it and they'll suck it into
like Splunk or some other log processing
service but we want to be the trusted
advisor for for Gary for his the
security of his network so there's it
kind of behooves us to provide strong
analytics directly within our product so
that Gary doesn't have to do stuff like
pulling out all this data all the time
so that's kind of the the context of how
data engineering a duo came to be now I
want to talk a little bit about some of
the things that we r have done in the
past twelve months or so and then a
little bit about what we're planning on
doing in the future so our first goal
was to improve the storage of this data
this particular data we decided probably
doesn't belong in my sequel long term in
order to be able to do really awesome
analytics on it we've looked at a few
different options we explored using
redshift in AWS DynamoDB we even
considered continuing to use my sequel
and coming up with a better way of
moving data into tables that had better
indices but ultimately we settled on an
application called elastic search and
there are a few reasons that we chose
elastic search it provided a very
flexible HTTP API for us to construct
very interesting and complex queries
against adding new data to elastic
search it was much less painful than
than doing this in my sequel we didn't
have to migrate entire tables we could
simply
if we if we did our indexing correctly
we could simply create a new index with
with the new fields defined or we could
simply throw new data at the existing
indexes and elasticsearch would
generally do the right thing for us we
also had some in-house experience with
elasticsearch already is it powers our
company's application logs so the logs
that our service gives back to us to
figure out if things are working
correctly so having that prior are kind
of helped us feel more comfortable with
using this that's not to say that there
weren't any drawbacks of using
elasticsearch being a security company
security is very important to us if if
that actors were able to gain access to
our customer logs that would be very
very bad so security being a very
important thing elasticsearch by default
has almost no security you stand it up
and you can throw requests at it and it
will give you your data back it doesn't
care who you are what you say you are
also these the indexes that kind of lay
underneath elasticsearch are known to
certain people to be brittle they could
be corrupted and lost and so having this
be our permanent storage for this off on
data kind of give us pause a little bit
so we had to come up with with some some
other ways to mitigate that which I'll
get into but despite this we were
comfortable using elasticsearch and so
we came up with a somewhat reasonable
architecture for for deployments we
decided to develop our own sort of proxy
application for elasticsearch we already
sort of had some I hesitate to use the
term micro services because it's kind of
a little buzz wordy but we had a bit of
a framework in place already for
creating new applications that could
talk to other applications within our
Amazon VPC using authentication and
authorization so that gave us
of happiness as far as far as a security
but when also hosting the last to search
in AWS AWS has elastic search as a
service and they also have their own
authentication layer on top of that so
double secure also by putting this this
sort of proxy application in here we
were able to basically only expose the
functionality of elastic search that we
want in our our applications to have a
bit about this Python service duo is
still on Python - for the most part and
we use twisted as any twisted users know
oh yeah way back there twist is fun it's
it's an event-driven framework if any of
you have used nodejs or async i/o it's
kind of the same sort of thing you have
this reactor that does events it
basically lets us deploy applications
without having to put some other web
server in front of it like g-unit corn
or whatever great for networking great
for web applications really steep
learning curve but we already had this
for our main service so we decided to
continue using it there were a couple
tools that we used to make our lives a
little bit easier when building this
application there's a tool out there
called cerebro not the thing that
Professor X wears in his head but a web
application that sits in front of
elasticsearch and basically lets you
craft queries in a web UI and fire them
off and then see what elasticsearch does
almost like using the command line for
my sequel but since last search speaks
Jason over over HTTP this kind of
interface lends itself a bit better to
exploring what elasticsearch can do we
also oh so this that cerebro tool is
very useful for development but if you
it doesn't support being stood up in
front of an AWS managed elasticsearch
because of there's their custom signing
algorithm so we developed our own
command
for me being able to fire off requests
to an AWS managed elasticsearch this was
very helpful for us in debugging some
production issues that came up okay so
we kind of have the storage mostly set
now the the one a goal was how do we
move all that data into elasticsearch
which proved to be a bit more of a
challenge for us than we had initially
anticipated so much like we had
developed our own application to be in
front of a last search we also wrote our
own custom application for basically
pulling data out of my sequel
transforming it sprinkling it with some
additional fund Atta and then shuffling
it off to to the service to get ingested
again written and twisted we did some
fun things like writing a process that
would instead of immediately shuffling
rose into elasticsearch would wait for a
few seconds to see if any more data was
going to come in elasticsearch is
happiest when you send it lots of data
in a single request rather than small
rows one at a time and the instances of
elasticsearch and my sequel weren't
exactly one-to-one so maybe we would
have a single cluster that would a
single elasticsearch cluster that would
serve several of our deployments and so
multiple databases were were ingesting
data to elasticsearch at one time so we
we had to do some things like adding a
cursor to each my sequel database so
that we could keep track of where we
were in the various sync processes I
touched on some of the numbers a little
bit but basically you know our largest
deployment had about almost two billion
rows on average we're looking at 60
million rows for most tables with the
median of about 3 million for most of
our deployments this sync process worked
pretty well straightaway
for a very larger ones we ran into some
issues where it would simply not be able
to keep up even with so I showed you
that one graph earlier with the billions
of rows this is this is the same data
but the rate in which new offs are
coming into our into our tables and
we're looking at maybe across everything
about 90 or so authentications per
second which I don't know it doesn't
sound like a whole lot but this this
process that we wrote was was barely
able to keep up with our largest our
second largest deployment and not able
to keep up at all with that 1.7 billion
row system so there were a few things
that we had to kind of go back and
optimize with this process one of them
being we're using twisted it's it's an
asynchronous framework but we were still
sending stuff serially and we would send
one batch over and we would wait for it
to come back and send another one over
and wait for it to come back by
parallelizing that we shaved a lot of
time off of the same process the other
thing to do a nice little fun Python
gotcha
we were assembling these bodies by
setting up a string transforming each
row and appending it to that string
turns out when you're doing millions of
these that results in millions of string
allocations we didn't catch this for a
little while and this is this is really
chewing up a lot of memory for us by
switching this over and using an array
and shoving each string into an array
and then joining at the end resulted in
much happier memory usage I the takeaway
from me on that was like we had a lot of
prior art with Python 2 and twisted and
it was great but Python lends itself in
my opinion very well to rapid
development it's a very approachable
language it's a very powerful language
but there are a lot of gotchas that you
might run into when you're starting to
do things
scaling you need things to work very
fast however all of that was III think
those those hang-ups were kind of worth
it in the long run because very able to
stand up something a lot more quickly
the other the other thing that I haven't
really touched on a whole lot but I
think is an important thing if you if
you think back to that slide of the cost
of fixing issues relative to where they
happen that's not just applicable to
bugs I think that's also applicable to
to the types of data you're developing
against and if you are not using
realistic data both in terms of scale as
well as the realism of the data the
differences between your two
environments are going to make it much
more harder to identify issues so if I
if I could have had another stab at this
what I probably would have done is is
developed against an actual cloud
instance maybe maybe getting a read
replica of one of our production
instances set up we have a we have a
very strong security mentality of
developers can't really touch what's
going on in production we have our own
production engineering teams that that
that do that but being able to get my
hands on a dataset that big would have
been very helpful okay so so now we have
the system now I have the data in it the
last thing that we've been working on is
presenting this stuff to our customers
more flexibly
than we currently were there was a slide
I kind of skipped over but I I meant to
describe what that was basically in our
product currently we have a single page
in the product that allows our customers
to basically explore that data in a
tabular format which is great if you
have maybe 50 rows total but once you
start getting into thousands or tens of
thousands and millions of rows to
micaceous to look at a table doesn't
really do much
must have strong filtering which again
we couldn't have because we were using
my sequel and we didn't have the right
indexes and so now that we had all the
right tools we we needed to build some
really awesome visualizations on top of
it
prior to this elastic certification we
were using these front-end tools called
high charts and data tables and if
you're if you're not too familiar with
front-end development basically these
are two front-end JavaScript libraries
that allow you to very quickly add
things like tables and graphs and charts
and stuff like that here to your web
interface we were using these libraries
because they they gave us a lot of
out-of-the-box functionality that we
needed to move and iterate quickly on
things with limited development
resources but this is it's really hard
to see but basically using these
libraries requires you to basically turn
a bunch of knobs everything is
configuration driven and not very
friendly for development purposes
especially when you want to be able to
do something very custom like our
product design team is wonderful and
they've been giving us these really
great designs for for data visualization
that are very specific on how things
should be laid out on the page and these
libraries we're really allowing us to do
this the way that we wanted to so for
for front-end development we started
looking at a couple of libraries called
reactive d3 anyone heard of react cool
all right
reacts the big thing is building user
interfaces in a component oriented way
and if you think about things like
reports and graphs and tables these are
very component driven you'll have like
your report will have a graph up here
and maybe a table down here and some
other graphs so so a component oriented
architecture kind of lines up very well
with with data visualization
react is not so great at some of the
more detailed aspects of data
visualization like number crunching and
drawing things like exceeds on graphs
and so we used another awesome library
called d3.js to sort of fill in the gaps
d3 is really great at number crunching
and doing really fine detail date of his
work so we were able to use these two
things in tandem to come up with a
pretty pretty good system for building
database for our product this is just a
code snippet of what that kind of looks
like things are much more programmatic
and less configuration driven and
ultimately you're able in our product to
add a donut graph to a page by simply
creating a new instance as this donut
graph rather than invoking this
third-party library and shoving this
massive javascript object into it so
that's kind of where we're at today I I
would still consider us to be a bit in
our infancy in terms of data
infrastructure and data visualization
but I think we're moving in the right
direction elasticsearch was a great
start for us for for getting better
analytics into our product but I think
lasting search doesn't solve all of our
use cases I think we have aspirations of
doing things more like near real time
and real time analysis of this data and
having a data pipeline in place will
really help us with that we're starting
to look at Apache Kafka down the road
here pretty soon and that will that and
other things our data science teams also
looking at using Apache spark to help us
start to process this off log data as
it's coming through so that we can do
things like monitor for fraudulent and
suspicious activity you know if Eva's
normally signs in for me Ann Arbor and
then suddenly we get an auth in from
China that we would want to you know
raise
vacation to Gary right away and having
some of these pipelines and processing
tools in place will help enable us do
that and continuing to iterate on these
these data visualization things that
we've started so that's that's all I
really have thank you all for listening
as I kind of said at the start there's
this is more of a broad talk than a deep
talk there's there's a lot of cool stuff
that we're doing that I could probably
go on for hours about but I don't have
the time for I simply just wanted to
kind of introduce duo introduce what
we're working on and just kind of share
a little more stories of sorts about
Howard's you know dealing with success
in dealing with scaling so again thank
you all for having me here today and if
there are any questions I would love to
hear them yes thank you yeah so I I will
repeat the questions the question was
this this 1.7 billion rows was this for
a single customer I I didn't mention
this duo was a multi-tenant service so
anyone deployment could house one
customer in the case of that 1.7 billion
one this is the one where if you were to
go to do a comm and sign up you would
end up in this particular deployment so
that that deployment has many customers
thousands a single my sequel database
correct or or in the case of sharding we
had we have several underneath but but
yeah single deployment can help house
many customers yeah yes
yes so the question was for some of the
other tech that we were looking at like
redshift or or [ __ ] were there any
features in there that we liked that
that we may be lost with the last search
was that probably the the thing that I
would have liked to see that Alaska
search didn't quite have so when we were
evaluating these things I don't think
elasticsearch was actually hosted by AWS
at the time or if it was it wasn't in
all of the regions that we wanted so we
were kind of preparing ourselves to roll
this stuff out ourselves and maintain it
and so at the time having AWS manages to
for us would have been great maybe a
particular feature redshift would have
been cool because we already know how to
write sequel queries and having to learn
this this this new way of querying stuff
was a little bit tricky yeah wait in the
back the I think the question was I
don't think the question was why wasn't
redshift the answer for us you know I I
think redshift was probably the one that
we were looking at the heaviest aside
from elasticsearch and and we do in fact
use redshift for other other purposes
in fact we do actually shift a lot of
this data that I've been talking about
and a redshift but we use it mainly for
our own internal exploration of the data
and I think and I'm not an expert on
redshift so so if I if I speak something
wrong I apologize from from what I
understand just simply throwing all this
data into a big redshift table wasn't
necessarily better than keeping it in a
big my sequel table so things like
indexing and I don't know about charting
but like the indexing bits would still
why I think that's about the best answer
I can give so I'm sure there are plenty
of valid reasons that we could have gone
with redshift this is this is just why
we kind of wanted elasticsearch yeah yes
do we have concerns about running our
stuff on AWS all the time our entire
service is run in AWS so their hosting
service for all versus running it
ourselves
yes yeah I know for a fact that it's
it's difficult for us to ask AWS
elasticsearch certain questions about
its health and how things are running
under the hood you can do with one that
you're running yourself that's been a
bit of a thorn in our sides nothing we
couldn't overcome but a lot of times
I've heard horror stories of people
running managed elasticsearch that if
they were to reach out to a ws for help
AWS would just say throw more nodes at
it or up your node size and go away
right we haven't really run into because
we're still kind of spitting this up we
haven't really run into too many like of
those nitty gritty problems that have
required that kind of like surgical
stuff yet I'm hoping it never comes to
that did you run your own you're in your
own okay take the wheel right if you
wait to see might actually plug it the
flow the next device considerations
so the question is can correct me if I
if I misinterpret any that the question
is in the adding indexes to the table we
would introduce right latency and did we
consider batching writes to that table
did it do that about okay so so so so
batching log data from these devices and
then writing into the table in bursts
yeah okay we have not considered doing
something like that specifically I what
would give me pause about that is the
fact that this data is very critical for
us and so by taking data and matching it
and then letting Eve proceed on you run
the risk of dropping that data on the
floor if something goes wrong if that
database were to go offline in between
the period when we let Eve go and when
we would write to that table we would
lose that data and so ensuring that that
data is written to the table is is
absolutely critical for us so I imagine
that would maybe not be a viable
solution for us dan it's your question
what are some of the bottlenecks to
watch for an elastic search and in
particular is that 1.7 billion records
okay
two-part question the first one is have
we found any bottlenecks in elastic
search in terms of query okay we haven't
run across too many bottlenecks yet I
think I'll ask to search for the most
part has handled everything we've thrown
at it in that 1.7 billion you mentioned
well I forget what what the second part
of that cost
that 1.7 billion we we take and we
depending on the deployment we will put
them in rolling indexes so like one for
June one from a one for one for each
month for some of us are smaller ones we
might put them into larger indexes and
then in the product itself we will kind
of restrict it to only maybe six months
of data or something like that so yeah
sanitaire question great there was they
yeah so to repeat the question
security was a concern for us and was
that because of any particular flaws in
Alaska search or just from the lack of a
standard security you like X pack or
something like yeah yeah so did we use
any of the add-on tools or where we
mainly looking at just the open source
core itself and and the answer to that
is we started off by looking just at
elasticsearch we were hesitant about
using the add-ons mainly because they
they would add authentication to it but
that still precludes
than the need to put elasticsearch in
isolated contained kind of environment
so because we don't want we don't want
to expose elastic search the internet
for any reason even if we had that
add-on in front of it right so because
of that we decided well we kind of need
to put this application in front of it
anyway and because our our framework
already had mechanisms for
authentication and authorization between
some of our internal services we decided
we didn't really need to use any of
those add-ons and then of course we
decided in the 11th hour that AWS has
managed blastic search where we need it
so we ended up getting that they have
they have user level permissions for
signing request to elastic search so it
ended up working out for us cool one
more yeah did we did we look at elastic
search his own hosted service and no I
think we were we were pretty dead set on
training either either you stuff at AWS
was giving us because we're all AWS or
or doing our own stuff on ec2 yeah yeah
we have a lot of legacy code if we
consider moving a Python 3 yes we
consider it all the time I would I would
love to get our service up on Python 3
in fact
a big fan of a ASA kayo and the new
async/await syntaxes oh it's wonderful
ultimately there would be a lot and in
fact twisted has pretty pretty good
interrupts with async IO now in version
17 or pretty recently so if we were to
migrate I I imagine at this point it
wouldn't be the worst thing in the world
2020 is still a long way away for us
yeah the drum to develop our product
continues to beat day to day and so it's
I would I would love for us to be able
to pick that up but yeah I'm very much
in tune with the whole we have to
balance what we have and the the legacy
of our existing code with the new stuff
we want to do duo's had a few greenfield
side projects where we've started using
Python 3 and those have worked out
wonderfully we are our core product is a
pretty big monolith I think over time
we're starting to add stuff separately
we chose for this particular project to
continue with that model but we've also
done stuff more Greenfield where we
build a new project from scratch and
then get those two things to talk to
each other even though they're pretty
separate code basis so yeah we're going
in that direction I hope we go a little
more quickly oh yes
[Music]
yeah the question was like the AWS yeah
okay
the question was am i exposed to what's
going on with with spark in our
organization unfortunately no I that's
more than going on with our data science
team and them being new as well they've
been kind of doing proof-of-concept
stuff on their own and in the coming
quarters we're going to start converging
and working on stuff together but I I
sadly don't know very little about spark
I'm going to become more familiar with
it in the next few months but yeah
that's all I have a four that all right
remind everybody please do sign up for
our lightning talks for October 10 and
let's give another big round of applause
for Ryan thanks